I don't think there should be divisions
I think you got 16 in each conference
everybody should play each other once
and that's 15 games okay and then if you
want a sixteenth game you play a natural
rival from the other conference you know
Jets and Giants play over your eagle
Steelers you know Texans Cowboys etc etc
play every year and then keep it at 16
games but you'll avoid the problem
that's gonna happen this year we're
probably an 8 & 8 team is hosting a 12
and 14 you're gonna get the six best
teams in each conference big fans you
offered up that idea earlier this week
and I absolutely loved it the NFL will
never ever ever do it but I love it
strip down the divisions have every team
in a given conference play every other
team
I don't like you'd only have one in her
conference game and maybe you go to 17
regular-season games so you have to
inter conference games but I love the
idea of determining the conference on a
pure meritocracy no guaranteed playoff
spot just because you happen to be the
best of four crap teams no guaranteed
home game in the playoffs because you
happen to be the best of four crap teams
the six best teams in the conference get
in and it's determined by a true
round-robin in the conference you play
everybody once why do you need to play
teams twice why do we need that that's
that's a vestige of the days that they
only had 12 teams in the league you got
to play somebody twice you can't finish
the season play everybody once tear down
the division walls make it to
conferences seed it that way you're
gonna get the best six teams out of that
approach I love it that's an idea that
somebody like Sean McVeigh should be
bringing the table that's not something
one of the oldest coaches in the NFL
should come up with I love it the NFL
never do it big cat would this idea is
terrible Mike you're terrible you kill
me with these things why why why would
we do this I want to play the patent
employ tell me why I want about hackers
Home & Away I want to see the the
Cowboys and the Eagles play twice a year
I want to see the rivalries that we grew
up on that we know so well to keep going
I don't want to have
one game against those teams every
single year stop this nonsense stop this
craziness what are you trying to do to
my league trying to improve it I'm
trying to all of it you already ruined
it last year with the pass interference
you know review the Mike Florio in
memoriam replay review now you're doing
this come on this is crazy and for the
record cuz I let you you make that dig I
never asked for what we have I want the
sky judge I still want sky judge no I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't but I
like this and here's what I like about
it I like the fact that there's somebody
that's willing to come up with creative
ideas they're never going to adopt this
but I love the fact that Vic Fangio is
throwing out ideas no more ideas that go
thrown out there eventually we will find
something it'll make things better
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports